bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fuori j oggi
siamo su pizzate liberi è sorto thriller
ma io direi di iniziare anche perché
cos'è e tardi è raggiunto l'ultimo a
casa nella lista degli ordini e consegne
la pizza velocemente ritorna a casa
che senso ha ma che cazzo di giochi
castiglia e alla ragazzi dobbiamo
consegnare una pia dalla casa amica che
non posso essere così ganzo con un
motorino e così tra l'altro raga che
cazzo di cancello è questo cosa deve
entrare un convoglio militare
vabbè alla ragazzi o la pizza cielo devo
consegnarla l'ambiente è fantastico
buongiorno ho sempre sognato di
consegnare delle pizze negli horror e
questo sogno finalmente si realizza
ragazzi possono segnare la mia pizza e
alla parte michael jackson dovremmo
ghetto non lo so pizze le leve
riconsegna pizza e poi per favore
aspettare all'interno prenderà i miei
soldi quando arriverò solo o anche i
ragazzi allora direi di entrare non ho
ben presente alla better place vizzon
dei modi
se mi sparano il copyright sono ragazzi
sono cazzi vostri
va bè ragazzi dopo salta pizza come
better playstation network e ragazzi
dopo dalla vita ce l'ho fatta ok non ho
ben capito qual è ok
cos'è successo ragazzi cos'è successo
benissimo si sono spente le luci allo
ragazzi non è che cazzo so su ragazzi
cos'è mamma è tutto a posto la sua ex
ragazza
c'è qualcosa che stai gocciolando dal
piano di sopra ho preso la candela sul
tavolo che non fa un cazzo di luce ma
non importa è già meglio di niente
credo che io debba arrivare al piano di
sopra ma non penso che questo un
telefono
devo arrivare acqua ci sono le scale per
effettuare o ragazzi cioè ragazzi è
successo di tutto in due tutti minotti
michael jackson pizza e vabbè io andrei
su bubi permesso devo consegnare una
pizarro messo di fatto sentito e non
fatemi dal male allora cosa devo fare
qui raga in teoria sangue dovrebbe
venire la sosta
che cazzo ok merda ragazzi
[Musica]
ok ragazzi allora non ho capito perché
c'è una che sta volando non l'ho capita
intanto li sto bruciando la mano io non
ho ben presente se a voi è mai capitato
di entrare in casa di qualcuno e beccare
uno così sul muro è un po una cosa
strana però va bene l'importante è che
abbia le tette poiché vuole forse sono
le tette che fanno da mongolfiera berni
in porta sentito il secondo che deve
uscire di qua io esco di qua vado di
sotto
vado di sotto perché mi hanno detto di
uscire e l'altro è buio pesto di fuori
c'è ancora mio motorino si de pizza che
è successo la pizza cosa che chissà che
che sta parlando de pizza e qui la pizza
hut hawaii raga è racchiusa la pizza lo
so chi è stato e michael dove michael di
dimmi che non sto qui dentro lo so
perché lui quando quando quando non lo
guardiamo ci si mette a ballare driller
esce tipo zombie e va a prendere la
pizza secondo me è stato molto sciocco
cela un senso ho sentito cose ma il mio
cellulare che sta suonando no e nel
gioco
è nel gioco cazzo pensavo fosse il mio
vabbè comunque direi di andare avanti
c'è la musica che viene di quando a ecco
la chitarra simone bastardo risponde sì
che cazzo succede ma no
cos'è come fatto a cadere se spiaccicato
atteso e sentito splat è decaduta aiuto
vi sono intrappolati in questa con chi
stai parlando a 6 parlando a ok quale
casa n fatemi uscire di qui ok cosa chi
sta calmati che sta succedendo dove sei
sto arrivando
io non posso parlare adesso non posso
parlare adesso sarò lì in un paio di
secondi
devi soltanto spiegarmi cosa fare
chiamata finita ok perfetto la l'utilità
vista chiamata è alle stelle cioè è già
arrivata
ma che cazzo è flash c'è questo è
successo aiuta sono intrappolando qui
con michael jackson aiuto aprite sono un
ragazzo delle pizze a favore fammi
uscire dove eni eni eni si e spiaccicata
su di lei
lei è morta il suo corpo volteggiava chi
sei tu chiamerò la polizia
ma no per favore ascolta aprì la porta è
stato michael cazzo è stato maicol in un
sacco di problemi no non meramente non
sono stato io
ascoltami brutto stronzo farmi uscire di
qui lo so che cosa sta succedendo
ok il medesimo forse un po troppo prof
ok ci sono le chiavi al piano di sopra
vai a prenderle ragazzi ma che stesso la
sto gioco
e allora non mi vuole salvare perché
crede che io abbia ucciso la tipa che si
è spiaccicata da sola io consegno pizze
non si può neanche più consegnare una
pizza e sto posto maledizione
devo andare a prendere delle chiavi ma
non ho capito di sopra da qualche parte
non so bene dove ci dovrebbero essere
dove cazzo dov'è finita tipo e ragga era
e dove cazzo cioè si spiaccica michael
sei tu che robbie la gente michael dove
sei
sentite un secondo ragazzo è qualcosa
che non va e cosa sta succedendo
allora ragazzi c'è c'era una tipa una
volta di sopra ma non c'è più e questo
può risultare un problema che allora non
vedo un cazzo allora salto sui mobili
tipo ezio anche se non ci sono chiari
qui perfetto non può subire questo mi
rassicura una maniera incredibile
dall'aset c'è una finestra tiro una
testata ed essi lasko posto fammi uscire
non ci sono chiavi ei non c'e nessuna
chiave qui ei sei ancora le ragazze ne
andandomi dire che se n'è andata
ma se n'è andata scommetto che mi sa ke
kazzo è successo oddio la pizza che
succede addio paranormal pizza raga
aiuto
cos'è che maicol che cazzo stai facendo
dove ti stai nasconde che sta sta
puntando il fuoco se spiegatemi cosa
dovrei fare io adesso devo andare di
stop ma perché stanno facendo avanti e
indietro ma senza un motivo c'è non ha
senso io non ho capito
oh cazzo
chi è questo buongiorno questo guai
cattivo di batman che ci fa qui queste
double face senti un attimo zio come ci
sei arrivato qui a te attento che ti ha
detto che tiri una capocciata della
madonna è attento cazzo raga ecco
perfetta l'avevo detto io perché se
un'opera d'arte fattelo dire amico mio
cosa dovrei fare qui adesso che c'è la
gente che volte
[Musica]
accrescendo ok ragazzi devo andare a
rispondere al telefono e penso sia
questo sia questo ragazzo veramente mi
sto prendendo male sto gioco non ha
senso
e io rispondo ormai sono depresso cioè
praticamente una volta che visto che di
giocare su giochi mi prendo la botta
raga che cazzo girati marcia [ __ ]
cos'è sta roba ma [ __ ] cos'era
cosa devo fare che cosa è successo
mio zio fortissimo de vos e cosa sta
succedendo ve sono adesso sto giocando
us lander cha abbiamo cambiato gioco
serio motore ci sono le fette di ragazzi
sono i prezzi di pizza a terra
devo seguire la pizza probabilmente non
lo so ragazzi io no
ma che cazzo ma chi è che fa sti giochi
ma cosa si è fumato caso c'è ma non ha
senso non ha senso
raga io ottima da adesso in avanti non
andrò mai più a comprare una pizza
perché non ha senso cos'è cosa son sì
così checa cos'è un meteorite cos'è
cos'è neve non chiusi capisce non è che
ma mi spunta slider raga la pizza sta
finendo e cos'è cos'è quella roba lì
kick ass
cos'è oddio ma perché
ma tu no la pizza la pizza no ragano no
raga non assenza cos'è successo
c'è praticamente alla fine c'erano i due
che volteggiavano a terra mano nella
mano si sono bruciati e la morale di
tutto questo è lei consegni la pizza
fredda sei autorizzato a bruciare in
poche parole è questo il messaggio del
gioco e io non voglio sapere perché non
lo voglio sapere perché mi avete
consigliato sta roba
non lo voglio sapere e comunque spero
che comunque video vi sia piaciuto come
al solito ragazzi 6 video è piaciuto
lasciato il commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come in ogni video
trovate nella descrizione
se non siet ago rischi discrete lines
vediamolo professioni dove le ragazze
[Musica]